hi I'm Avan Jogia author of mixed
feelings and general actor and person
who breathes welcome to my first first
quote that comes to mind when you think
of your victorious character Beck Oliver
lean he liked to lean on stuff that was
his main top number one thing he liked
to do is to lean on lockers and in all
walls and also boots like combat boots
they look the heaviest combat boots I've
ever worn in my entire life first
impression of your victorious to coast
are already on the Grande well my first
impression of both Liz and Ahri is that
they sang a lot because they both came
from Broadway so they were just doing
show tunes all the time which is
hilarious to me because I mean I'm just
not the showtune type I don't know if
that's coming across so that was my
first impression of Ari but also my
first impression of woods in general my
first kiss so the gym at my high school
had I say high school I didn't really go
to high school was like like two years
like grade 9 in grade 10 but that had
the gymnasium had like this you know
it's like like found the Opera rafters
so we would go up there and I I made out
we made out there it was the thing to do
because you know gym class right first
time you were starstruck oh I love this
story okay so I was like I just first
moved to LA I was like 17 years old I
dropped out of high school to it to move
to LA and I was in an elevator going to
like a general meeting or some sort of
thing this guy walks onto the elevator
and he has this big straw hat on and
this like ruffled green shirt with a
green bow tie and then I was like that's
Andre 3000 and he's headed going
like to himself because he knew I was
watching and I was like that's very cool
first memory from the set of Victorious
before we started shooting at Nick on
Sunset we shot at this studio called the
Ren Mar I don't even know if the I think
they'd say completely I think it's worn
down or a completely different studio
now and we shot there and they gave us
this little like early like digital
camcorders like something that like it's
like completely archaic technology now
like you would never you know you
wouldn't even know how to use it but if
they gave us these little cam course
like document our I wonder where all
that footage I think Matt Bennett has
all that footage first career aspiration
actually my first career aspiration is I
wanted to be a writer I wanted to be an
author which I've hilariously done
randomly with mixed feelings last-minute
did not know I was going to be writing
the poetry book but at my first scent
spray I want to be unlike a poet I want
to be like a like a 17th century poet I
wanted to be like frilly shirts and lots
of like absence that's sort of a general
like thing I wanted to do realized not
really that fun to do any of that lot of
syphilis like not a good time
but I'd still love poetry and I still
loved that type of romantic poetry and
now you know this year or mixed feelings
I actually am a writer no less absence
less syphilis less Felicia actually no
same amount of frilly shirts
I still wear like the same amount of
frilly shirts as I dreamt I was going to
be able to wear so first role you really
wanted that went to someone else I have
to say like my I've gotten a little Zen
master about the auditioning process I
don't really care and I don't mean to I
don't mean to be flippant about that I
just I just my job is to like do the
best performance that I can give to each
character that I am if I'm just a
character for one audition for like four
minutes eight minutes and I'm doing my
best version of that and that's where I
get the joy because I perform a small
play for the eight or three people that
are in the room and so I've changed my
psychology about the auditioning process
I'm not in competition with anyone so I
don't really pay attention to who gets
parts that I that I didn't I don't care
first time I was recognized in public I
don't really remember this it just
started happening all of a sudden I the
weirdest time I was ever recognized in
public I was in Bali on the back of a
moped
in the middle of just rice paddies
everywhere and this guy buzzes uh
next to me on a moped he was like you're
from tut I know you from tied like
really that's amazing Jesus's random
Balinese guy on a moped was like I know
you that was the weirdest experience
then you know it's this is the thing
about what we do is like you know
information goes everywhere so quick
like this video is gonna be seen by
somebody and you know Romania and I'm
you know that's weird to me first book
that you read or connected with so in
line with the whole poetry thing
telltale hearts by Edgar Allen Poe I had
the complete works of Edgar Allen Poe
and I went to my third-grade class and
read them like show-and-tell read them
with with a lot of passion too much
passion will say and they were very
scared and it was I was I was asked to
sit down first thirsty fan reaction no
one's ever asked me for water or
anything like this no I don't know I you
get you get crazy interactions on
Instagram of thirsty people I think
people and more thirsty on the Internet
I think it allows people like thinking
like get away but you know it's funny
because people don't flirt in public
anymore like with each other they flirt
like all they flirt like online and then
they like then they're like shy in
public which i think is a very
interesting energetic shift in our
culture it's like no one actually like
flirts with you in public anymore my
first job I started acting when I was
very young
I started acting when I was like I'm
very young I was like 14 so the first
job I had was actually an acting job and
it was a commercial for a yogurt if I
remember correctly and that also I did a
commercial for Harry Potter board game
of a variety that I can't remember and
it's because I could do like a faux
English accent I was like Scotland
speech it was my line that was my life
commercials a lot a lot of commercials
excitable ethnically ambiguous kid eats
slop for money first classmate that I
bonded with on the set of Zombieland
double tap I think me and Jesse bonded a
lot I mean me and Abigail do most of our
scenes together so obviously we bought
it but the thing that stands out to me
is is is holding a bit of fence there's
this part where like you know making a
zombie barricade we just held this bit
offense for like three days
straight because it takes so long to do
all the zombies stuff like a zombie
stunts and the thing and the you know
special effects and all the stuff so
you're just in the background holding a
bit of fence it's the free taste it's a
very weird job you know it's like you
want to be an actor oh great what are
you gonna do hold a bit of fence for
three days first time you realize you
want to pursue acting my snobby response
to this is panic in needle park and
although that is true that's what made
me want to be like it sure like you know
Al Pacino is amazing in that movie the
truth is it's probably Tim Curry in
Muppets Treasure Island that's the truth
I was like I want to be a pirate and my
mum was like he can't be a pirate so I
was like okay so what is what is that
then well that's an actor playing a
pirate I said well then I want to be an
actor first incorrect rumor you read
about yourself I mean dating rumors are
funny there's so many dating rumors yeah
I like finding out who I've dated that's
fun I'm like oh I don't remember that I
don't remember dating Eva Longoria
that's not really first TV show you bins
watched the first show I binge-watched
was a Black Adder
that's a UK comedy so I've been watched
that and I've been watched Red Dwarf
another UK comedy yeah we do it at
Christmas time that's when that's the
best when we used to scene back in the
day guys we used to binge-watch around
Christmas it was like a time of the year
where everyone stopped doing what
they're doing and just watched
television and now that time is all
around my first acting credit this movie
called the Gwen Araujo story which was
directed by Ignacio Holland who directed
Europa Europa sort of a it's an intense
movie about the death of a trans woman I
was like the younger brother because I
down a bunch of commercials up into that
point it was fun to like act in scenes
and do real acting so that was an
interesting experience for me first red
carpet events man when you're on Disney
Nickelodeon it's hard to it's like this
this first carpet events it's so hard to
keep trying I think it was like some
Knott's Scary Farm kids choice variety
power of youth something I don't know I
have no idea I was I just I honestly was
just going to stuff because my friends
were going
I was like I want to hang out with my
friends I'd never had any idea where I
was at
I still don't where are we so my book
mixed feelings is out anywhere you can
buy books it's basically just an
exploration of my racial background and
what it is to be a mixed-race person so
check it out
[Music]